ravi de vous retrouver sur public sénat
cette semaine vous le savez la
commission des lois du sénat a organisé
plusieurs tables rondes pour préparer à
l'examen en séance publique le 24 mai
prochain du projet de loi de réforme de
la décentralisation
les sénateurs auditionnent cet après
midi les ministres marylise lebranchu et
anne marie escoffier sur ce thème
une réforme loin de faire l'unanimité
alors tout de suite direction la salle
médicis pour écouter ses auditions bon
après midi à tous bien eux
mesdames les ministres mes chers
collègues nous allons aussi ouvrir cette
séance
je voulais vous dire mesdames les
ministres
au nom de tous mes collègues ici
rassemblés nombreux que nous sommes
heureux de vous accueillir avec eux les
de nombreux sénateurs et sénatrices de
toutes les commissions avec madame
jacqueline gourault présidente de la
délégation aux collectivités locales et
avec les rapporteurs des diverses
commissions
monsieur rené rang devant d'irène donc
pour la commission des lois
monsieur jean germain pour la commission
des finances monsieur claude dilain pour
la commission du développement
économique et monsieur fillol qui va
sans doute nous rejoindre pour la
commission du développement économique
mesdames les ministres eux je voulais
vous dire que nous accordons forcément
au sénat ça ne vous étonnera pas
beaucoup d'importance aux projets
concernant les collectivités locales et
la décentralisation
sur ce sujet puisque le gouvernement a
inscrit le premier des textes à l'ordre
du jour du sénat pour le 30 mai que la
commission des lois sera saisi pour une
première réunion le 14 mai qu'il y a les
périodes d'interruption
nous avons fait le maximum et je peux
vous dire que nous avons passé les deux
dernières journées a procédé à
l'audition de quarante élus en séance
publique
ces élus nous ont parlé avec leur coeur
avec leurs raisons aussi et nous avons
engrangé beaucoup de remarques de toute
nature qui seront précieuses pour
nourrir le débat
je ne vais pas faire une longue
introduction je vais simplement vous
dire que vous nous aviez présenté au
départ un seul texte nous sommes un
certain nombre de sénateurs à avoir
souhaité et izon le franchement on a le
droit de s'exprimer en ce sens qu'il y
ait trois textes qui soit chacun court
avec un objet précis et qu'ils fussent
présenter tous les trois ensemble et
discuter tous les trois ensemble de
manière à ce que l' architecture fut
particulièrement lisible bien il y a eu
une division en trois textes
je ne suis pas sûr que l'on ait atteint
pleinement les objectifs que certains
d'entre nous souhaiter et que beaucoup
d'élus que nous avons rencontré souhaité
mais le travail du parlement commence il
n'y a pas de procédure accélérée dont à
nous de travailler et je vais encore
dire une phrase pour dire que s'il y a
un message et je parle devant témoin
puisque beaucoup d'entre vous ont
assisté à des auditions
où les ont vues sur les écrans un
message que nous ont lancé les élus que
nous avons reçu toutes tendances et
toutes catégories si je puis dire c'est
un simplicité que l'on comprenne les
réformes et qu'il y ait confiance dans
les libertés locales par exemple
voyez vous je crois que tous les
présidents de région de département
savent qu'il est utile de se concerter
des avec des autres mais lorsqu'il voit
apparaître des instances comportant 60
personnes pour définir un certain nombre
de schémas enchevêtrés les uns avec les
autres et bon on se dit que ça risque
d'être un petit peu compliqué je connais
les motivations les raisons mais est ce
que l'on ne peut pas tous ensemble avant
c'est à partir du très précieux
documents des documents que vous nous
apportez vers la lisibilité la
simplicité la confiance faite aux élus
pour travailler ensemble selon des
modalités qu'il peuvent aussi définir et
en même temps nous savons qu'il nous
faut des régions fortes par rapport à
l'économie et à l'emploi
nous savons qu'il nous faut des
métropoles d'avenir nous savons que les
communes elles nous sont chers comme la
prunelle de nos yeux parce qu'elles sont
la proximité et le coeur battant de la
démocratie et qu'il faut articuler
l'intercommunalité dans ses différentes
moutures et que le département est
totalement précieux pour toutes les
solidarités bien alors il s'agit d'aller
vers l'avant
bon j'arrête là nous allons donner
pendant dix minutes ça vous va où un
quart d'heure qu'est ce que vous voulez
la parole oui à chacune de nos ministes
puisque nous avons la chance
tout ce que vous voulez c'est la liberté
nous avons la chance d'avoir deux
ministres madame marylise lebranchu et
madame anne marie escoffier donc je
donne la parole pour commencer à
marylise lebranchu
merci monsieur le président j'entendais
un nombre des auditions je vous ferai
compte-rendu peut-être un jour de
l'ensemble des rencontres que nous avons
pu avoir en amont de l'écriture de ce
projet de loi vous en ferez votre miel
mais il faudra effectivement beaucoup
d'heures pour pouvoir les consulter
moi je voudrais rappeler simplement en
charge de ce dossier avec anne marie
escoffier que effectivement je vous
remercie des travaux importants que vous
avez conduit depuis le début de la
semaine
j'ai eu de nombreuses auditions très
riche nous n'avons pas pu encore toutes
les visionner ou les lire mais nous le
ferons
et effectivement ce projet de loi ce
projet je le présente encore comme tel
ça s'inscrit dans un contexte qu'il est
important de rappeler d'abord la
modernisation de l'action publique
il nous semble important 21e siècle de
faire attention à ce que l'action
publique sa portée avec un regard
d'avenir effectivement et la modération
de l'action publique les évolutions des
politiques publiques que nous conduisons
actuellement sont aussi un regard porté
y compris sur l'action publique des
collectivités territoriales la
modernisation de l'action publique aussi
les négociations avec la fonction
publique
un agenda social bien écrit je crois par
le premier ministre lui-même au mois de
juillet dernier qui comporte beaucoup de
volets et ses biens à l'intérieur de ce
grand schéma de la modération de
l'action publique et de l'évolution de
la fonction publique pour un 21e siècle
le service public soit de qualité que
nous avons été chargés aussi d'adapter
ce qu'on appelle aujourd'hui les lois de
décentralisation en rappelant qu'en même
temps nous souhaitons et le premier
ministre il ya répondu favorablement que
soit associé à l'assemblée nationale
deux textes qui sont issus de vos rangs
l'adaptation des normes et le statut de
l'élu
parce que tout ça ne fait qu'un il
faudra que nous soyons toujours attentif
il n'y a qu'un engagement par rapport à
l'ensemble des élus de france
il s'agit donc de décider la puissance
publique et les services publics du 21e
siècle dans une société en crise les
pros ce les français ont besoin de
services publics et quelques procès qui
a pu avoir sur les gabegies sur les
dépenses excessives et c'est non sans
doute pas lieu d'être
nous voyons bien à quel point d'ailleurs
dans ce contexte difficile les projets
des collectivités territoriales et leurs
évolutions sont au coeur des soucis de
nos citoyens même s'ils ne l'expriment
pas ainsi puisque je crois et je suis
déterminé à le rappeler aussi souvent
que possible profondément comme vous
sans doute que si nous n'avions pas eu
un réseau d'élus locaux sont de tous les
territoires de france nous aurions eu
encore plus de mal à passer ce cap
difficile d'une crise qui a débuté en
le projet de loi a en plus l'ambition de
respecter la diversité des territoires
et de s'inscrire dans un mouvement de
confiance envers les élus locaux
beaucoup nous l'ont dit marié et
moi-même et sûrement beaucoup avouent
aussi ont eu parfois une forme de
fatigue
à lire ses marronniers sur le gaspillage
de l'argent public sur les élus laxiste
qui ne prendraient pas en compte la
rationalisation de la dépense publique
dans leurs beaux hôtels de région de
département ou de ville et c'est vrai
que nous avons opté pour un texte qui
reconnaissent après trente ans de
décentralisation que les élus ont bien
agi
ils ont agi en concertation les uns avec
les autres et qu'il faudra sans doute
continuer à oeuvrer en ce sens et fort
de cette expérience nous appuyons donc
sur la confiance des élus nécessité de
l'action publique nous avons présenté un
texte qui effectivement j'ai envie de
dire une expression à tout à fait adapté
mais qui fait écho à ce que vous venez
de dire monsieur le président qui s'est
chargé d'un certain nombre de dix
cription je pense à formation
professionnelle où on transporte le
problème du droit positif français ce
que les choses doivent être écrites et
que parfois doivent être écrites avec
l'article 1 2 3 4 et j'en passe
donc c'est vrai que au fur et à mesure
texte qui était assez court s'est
enrichie d'abord des travaux du sénat je
rappelle que les assises les wiz et si
je dis bien de la démocratie locale qui
sont terminées à la sorbonne ont enrichi
beaucoup ne texte que nous avions
préparé ce rayon très froid entre nous
tous avant la campagne électorale elle
même et pendant deux ans de travaux que
futur président de la république nous
avait demandé s'est enrichi de ces états
généraux et du discours du 5 octobre
des discours du 7 octobre discours du
président la république et les discours
du président du sénat compte tenu de la
difficulté à passer ce texte de plus de
140 articles facilement au sénat dans le
temps qui nous était imparti
décision a donc été prise pour un gain
de temps bien sûr mais un gars de
maniabilité au niveau du parlement de
présenter le texte en plusieurs parties
nous avons donc un projet de
modernisation de l'action publique qui
n'est pas un texte métropole et je tiens
à le dire tout de suite parce que ce
serait une erreur que de le présenter
ainsi qu'à un projet de loi de
mobilisation
bien sûr des régions pour la croissance
et l'emploi la mobilisation des
départements pour l'égalité des
territoires il dit traduit les priorités
du président de la république et du
premier ministre l'ensemble des
territoires de france c'est un projet de
loi de développement des solidarités
parce que nous croyons aujourd'hui qu'à
côté de la compétitivité la solidarité
est essentielle à l'avenir de notre pays
avant de poursuivre je tiens à vous
confirmer monsieur le président vous
l'avait induit tout à l'heure dans votre
propos qu'il n'y aura bien évidemment
pas de procédure d'urgence et que la
réforme sera fait affaire avec vous qui
aurez donc une large place à
l'initiative parlementaire
je rappelle aussi que le 5 octobre
françois hollande a annoncé quatre
objectifs pour ce projet de loi qu'il
nous a réaffirmé avec le premier
ministre anne marie escoffier moi même
la confiance la clarté la cohérence et
la démocratie efficacité de l'action
publique pour nous c'est un objectif
essentiel il faut que nous puissions
démontrer à l'ensemble des citoyens
français que cette réforme témoigne de
la confiance dont l'état et dans les
collectivités locales et territoriales
pour mettre en oeuvre l'action
ce projet après 30 ans comme je le
disais tout à l'heure de
décentralisation de libre administration
des collectivités proposent une libre
organisation de l'action publique et
cette libre organisation de l'action
publique qui fait sa nouveauté fait
aussi parfois naître des sentiments
l'interrogation sinon de perplexité ce
n'est pas une nouvelle vague de
décentralisation il reste peu de
compétences à transférer vous le savez
de tous est donc un acte fort de
modernisation de l'action publique qui
doit contribuer au redressement
économique et social du nos territoires
parce qu'il n'ya pas de redressement de
la france en redressement des
territoires qui doit confier aux acteurs
publics les moyens d' en oeuvre de
mettre en oeuvre nos priorités et après
ce texte anne marie escoffier en
particulier chargé de conduire un
certain nombre de groupes de travail sur
les finances locales à la fois pour le
projet de loi de finances 2014 et le
projet de loi de finances 2015 on y
reviendra s'il ya des questions mais
nous voulons permettre aux collectivités
de prendre toute leur part pour le
retour de la croissance pour le retour
de l'emploi une retour de la confiance
le texte qui nous occupe aujourd'hui est
donc l'acteur inde approté d'un projet
de loi et non pas l'acte iii de la
décentralisation principales phases
réaffirmé dans un premier titre la libre
administration des collectivités
territoriales c'est important de le
faire et en particulier dans cette
enceinte affirmé le rétablissement de la
clause générale de compétence je sais
que ça a été extrêmement contestée
parfois applaudi ailleurs mais le
président de la république s'y était
engagé parole a été donnée à condition
bien sûr qu'ils aient des chefs de file
bien identifiés et que nous puissions
faire confiance aux élus de france parce
qu'ils en sont largement capables ils
l'ont souvent démontré de créer au sein
d'une conférence territoriale de
l'action publique dans chaque région un
pacte de gouvernance des cris des cris
signé pour que chaque compétence qui de
toute façon est ou sera mise en oeuvre
par différentes collectivités
au nom du principe de la libre
administration et celui de la clause de
compétence générale
et bien que cette compétence par exemple
développement économie puisse être lu
par les citoyens avec une région
déterminant des filières des grandes
stratégies d'innovation de transfert de
technologie ou de transfert de
ressources
et puis des villes appelées parfois
métropole les agglomérations ou des
départements
prenons en charge l'organisation des
zones d'activité immobilier d'entreprise
par exemple
première chose donc faire confiance
conduira ce qui est cette conférence de
l'action publique l'a parfois choqué
parce que nous y habitons le
représentant de l'état fait partie de
ceux et celles qui pensent que la
régionalisation et fait extrêmement
important que la france a connu et
connaîtront encore mais que la
régionalisation de l'action publique la
décentralisation de l'action publique
1 toute chance de réussir à une seule
condition c'est que l'état soit fort que
l'état ce regard en est que l'état soit
protecteur que l'état ça donc présents
le jour où dans une région et pas dans
une autre pour des raisons de vo graphie
d'histoire de culture bien les uns
demandent une délégation de compétences
supplémentaires alors que les autres ne
lui demanderons pas vous ne trouverez
pas à ce sujet le mot expérimentation ça
a été une diction d'exception pour
beaucoup en fait le mot expérimentation
vous le savez est lié un texte désormais
fondamental qui dit que toute compétence
transférée pour expérimentation doit
être appliquée à l'ensemble des autres
collectivités ou bien retirés à la
collectivité qui l'a demandé et nous
pensons nous aujourd'hui qu'à
l'intérieur des régions des départements
de france et d agglo et communautés de
communes rurales aussi il est très
possible de voir confier une compétence
par délégation l'eau est demandée en
bretagne par exemple je suis toujours la
même pour éviter de faire une autre
erreur et d'autres régions de france ne
la demande pas si au bout de cinq ans
l'évolution de la politique publique
montre que c'est une bonne idée ce n'est
pas une raison pour la transférer à
toutes les régions de france où la
retirer à la région qu'il a demandé d'où
cette présence de l'état à conférence
territoriale qui fait problème vous avez
raison sur un point certain nombre de
présidents de région de président
d'agglomération présidents de
communautés de communes rurales nous
disent pourquoi serais-je à la même
table et sous l'autorité du président du
conseil régional
moi j'ai envie de vous répondre tout de
suite parce que la question sera sans
doute poser c'est sans doute par
facilité que nous avons confiée au
président du conseil régional qui est le
seul à avoir seule collectivité sur
chaque région de france
l'organisation de ces conférences mais
il s'agit d'organisations et pas de
détermination d'ordre du jour et de
fines et milk premier point ce second
point l'affirmation du fait urbain le
président de la république qui tient
elle avait rappelé le 5 octobre après
vos travaux qui ont montré à la fois
grande attention à la ruralité et une
demande de reconnaissance du fait vroum
à régler les problèmes de paris lyon
marseille parce que il est important que
ces grandes agglomérations qui ont une
loi spécifique aujourd'hui qui reste
droit positif importante pas la loi dite
plm était important pour nous d'acter
que deux grandes questions doivent être
réglés à paris la grande question du
logement est celle du transport donc on
propose que sur la zone dense en
particulier il y ait des autorités
qu'ils soient organisatrice dans un
cadre régional bien définis qu'on a
apaisé je pense les craintes de la
région ile de france
elle n'arrive reviendra tout à l'heure
sur lyon / mars n y dossier difficile
s'il en est le premier ministre lui même
après que nous ayons fait quelques
visites sur le territoire a constaté
avec beaucoup d'entre nous que l'état a
rempli ses missions sur le port
l'aéroport gardanne fosse 6 ter certain
nombre de grands outils mais qu'en
revanche il ya de grandes difficultés
d'organisation de l'hinterland du port
mais aussi de l'ensemble de aix
marseille provence avec malheureusement
quelques embolie concernant les
transports quelques problèmes de
répartition du logement et puis des
entrepreneurs qui se plaignent de
grandes difficultés comme leurs salariés
d'où l'intérêt je crois de permettre aux
intercommunalités de se réunir pour
répondre aux grandes questions du
développement économique du logement du
transport et de l'environnement et rien
d'autre et on y reviendra sans doute
dans le débat avec le respect de la
proximité ont généré par les conseils de
territoire et enfin nous devons agir
vite
devons agir vite parce que fait urbain
vous l'avez remarqué pendant les
premières auditions
c'est à la fois de grandes chances mais
parfois de très grandes difficultés
il faut penser aux organisations
territoriales pour répondre aux
difficultés que les uns et les autres
connaissent c'est aussi une grande
chance que ce soit paris lyon marseille
ou les autres agglomérations qui
prétendront un autre statut je pense que
nous avons la possibilité après trente
ans de décentralisation de faire un
bilan et en même temps de faire
confiance faire confiance parce que le
bilan est positif parce qu'il a généré
de grandes réalisations parce que la
décentralisation a permis à tous les
territoires de francs sans aucun doute
je dis bien sans aucun doute le
progresser nous espérons aujourd'hui
qu'avec le développement économique
qu'il a prises en compte
encore plus précise de la jeunesse dans
le cadre des régions et des
intercommunalités plus forte
nous n'oublierons pas dans le texte
suivant les solidarités sociales et
territoriales sont un grand levier de
l'action publique que les départements
pourront accompagner
lorsque les trois textes cette fois
seront votés nos intercommunalités nos
régions de france une commune rurale et
nos communes urbaines a participé mieux
et bien j'espère au développement de la
france
merci madame la ministre je donne la
parole à madame anne marie escoffier
e ministre délégué chargé de la
décentralisation
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs aux propos de
de marylise lebranchu je dois dire que
sur les principes en propre je n'ai pas
grand chose à rajouter
sauf peut-être à reprendre des mots qui
chaque fois chaque fois que nous
rencontrons les élus ont un écho fort
ses mots c'est le mot confiance je crois
que ils ont été prononcées ici à de
nombreuses reprises et moi je veux
témoigner que dans les rencontres qui
sont les nôtres sur le terrain
cette confiance chaque fois que l'on
explique ce vers quoi nous voulons aller
ce mot confiance prend un sens il a un
sens je te dire que le texte que nous
avons voulu élaborer
je ne vais pas revenir sur son
architecture on en reparlera sûrement
dans le cadre des questions
le texte avait trois objectifs trois
objectifs qu'il faut bien retenir les
trois objectifs c'est l'efficacité il
était clair qu'aujourd'hui ce que vous
nous voulions faire ce que nous voulons
faire avec vous avec les élus
c'est rendre à l'action publique toute
son efficacité
après des années un dispositif où la
complexité était venu s'introduire et
chacun l'a dit et chacun l'a constaté
entre l'état d'une part et les
différentes collectivités territoriales
et niveaux de collectivités
territoriales premières orientations
première priorité l'efficacité deuxième
priorité absolue c'était la
clarification est vraiment dans ce texte
qui vous est proposé à bien vouloir le
lire à bien vouloir y chercher le sens
vous y trouverez justement les grandes
lignes de cette volonté de clarification
entre chacun des niveaux
mais au delà des niveaux entre chacun
des modes d'organisation de
fonctionnement de gouvernance des
niveaux et puis le troisième la
troisième priorité essentielle celle là
aussi et je crois que
madame lebranchu l'a bien dit dans le
cadre de son intervention dans le
contexte qui est le nôtre
la priorité absolue c'est la maîtrise
des dépenses
et c'est pour ça que vous le nôtre est
aussi bien en ce qui concerne le
fonctionnement des régions et de nos
départements qui sont là les zones d'
équilibre du territoire en ce qui
concerne les métropoles qui
correspondent à une priorité à fait
nouveau pour la et l'autre l'objectif
chaque fois et de mettre en place un
dispositif qui parviennent à réduire les
dépenses des uns et des autres nous
sommes donc bien là dans un texte qui a
pour objectif de développer la
solidarité des solidarités en préservant
dans tous les cas et on aura l'occasion
de le dire
concernant les conférences territoriales
de l'action publique
le principe constitutionnel de libre
administration des collectivités
territoriales
je crois que nous pourrons dès lors
évoqué ensemble l'organisation plus
global du texte parce que effectivement
comme l'a dit votre président il y a un
instant l'objectif était bien d'avoir
cette unité
cette cohérence aujourd'hui est la
cohérence
elle reste dans la présentation que nous
avons fait
elle reste dans les textes que nouveau
présentant même si dans le temps dans le
temps nous sommes amenés à découper le
texte en trois volets distincts trois
temps les trois temps qui sont trois
temps de réflexion pour que chacun se
nourrissent de l'autre et permettent
justement d'améliorer cette cohérence au
sein des trois collectifs de
collectivités territoriales de la région
des départements du bloc intercommunal
avec la spécificité la singularité
on y reviendra tout à l'heure deux des
métropoles telles que nous les avons
conçu voilà en quelques mots monsieur
président pour ma part je ne voulais pas
aller au delà parce que je crois que
nous allons après
rentré dans le dans le fond dans le fond
des textes dire mot quand même
en ce qui concerne le deuxième texte
le deuxième texte qui est celui de
l'égalité des territoires
je veux y assister parce que il est
vraiment le complément ou prou en tout
cas il est le creuset dans lequel entre
les métropoles
le deuxième texte c'est bien celui de
cette égalité des territoires dans
lequel il y a à côte à côte les régions
les départements ces départements qui
sont et pour reprendre les mots que vous
avez dit tout à l'heure sur le président
qui sont incontournables aujourd'hui qui
sont ces lieux de solidarité qui sont ce
lien entre toutes les collectivités et
dont aujourd'hui chacun a reconnu la
nécessité pour être en proximité des
citoyens
voilà je crois que c'est là un des
points essentiels de la construction de
l'architecturé des textes qui vous sont
proposés même si aujourd'hui nous
travaillons spécifiquement sur sur le
premier texte
j'en viendrais à parler mais dans je
pense au cours de cette audition
plus spécifiquement de la métropole
lyonnaise qui est j'allais dire une
métropole singulière en quelque sorte
puisque est là elle entre elles avec son
statut de collectivité de plein exercice
une singularité encore une fois qui qui
répond à sa géographie physique mais à
son histoire à sa culture et qui a
permis aujourd'hui de mettre en place ce
dispositif
encore une fois singulier unique et puis
nous aurons à parler des métropoles de
droit commun qui elles vont se mettre en
place aussi et qui corresponde à ce fait
urbain que l'on a indiqué tout à l'heure
voilà monsieur présidence que j'aurais
pu ajouter concernant le sur un plan
plus général
merci mesdames les
ministre alors mes chers collègues de
manière à être efficace à ne pas trop
faire attendre les associations d'élus
qui que nous allons entendre à la suite
de cette audition
et hier et avant-hier on a eu toujours
du mal à tenir le débat mais comme tout
le monde est intéressé par tous les
débats ça tombe bien nous allons je vous
propose de donner d'abord la parole à
nos trois rapporteurs puis à chacun de
ceux qui voudront s'exprimer puis de
donner la parole à nos deux ministres
pour répondre à l'ensemble des orateurs
parce que si on fait autrement peut-être
certains collègues ne pourront pas
s'exprimer ou trop tardivement
tout le monde est d'accord sur la
méthode la parole est à monsieur van
beirendonck rapporteur de la commission
des lois mais d'amener mini ce monsieur
le président mes chers collègues
première remarque jeffrey et lé
importante parce que elle donne de la
perspective
j'ai tout de suite posé une question
vous avez rappelé monsieur sûr avec une
honnêteté intellectuelle dont il ne se
départit jamais à rappeler que le sénat
était à l'origine des trois tomes
vous avez dit vous même qu' il
s'agissait d'un texte qui repose sur la
confiance et je crois qu'il y avait un
signe qui était attendu par beaucoup de
monde au sénat qui était le sort qui
serait réservé notamment par le
gouvernement aux deux propositions de
loi sur lesquels j'ai eu l'occasion de
travailler d'ailleurs avec cette grande
administration qui est la dgcl et ceux
non moins grand sénateur qui
richard celui donc sur l'allègement des
normes et celui sur le statut de l'élu
qui est par les temps qui courent
attendu comme la soif attend l'oranje
tellement la saison et aux amalgames et
au traitement inégalitaire
donc merci d'avoir été clair là dessus
c'est vrai que ce qui sécuriserait la
démarche me semble-t-il après ses 40
heures et plus d'auditions qui n'ont
rien à envier à au cycle des
concertations auquel vous avez procédé
c'est d'avoir quand même des éléments
précis de calendrier d'examen des trois
tomes et dans mes rêves les plus fous de
savoir peut-être quand le tome 2 ou le
tome 3 dont on nous dit que les
intitulés pourrait varier vont être
examinés et on pourrait même imaginer
que les rapporteurs sur ces questions
soient désignés dans un temps qui leur
permettent de travailler peut-être d'une
manière moins moins pressante 1 que pour
ce texte
ça c'est la première remarque que je
voulais faire là elle est importante
parce que elle conditionne justement ce
que vous avez appelé le climat de de
confiance
qui va s'instaurer donc ensuite je
reprendrai et éventuellement la parole
sur d'autres questions mais je ne veux
pas occuper tout le débat mais c'est
cette manière d'entrer dans ce débat
conditionne la tonalité qu'il va avoir
tout le long de son déroulé merci
monsieur le rapporteur jean germain
rapporteur de la commission des finances
merci monsieur le président mesdames les
ministres donc je vais peut-être rentrer
un peu plus avant que mon collègue
on est 22 rennes manquait d'abord sur
des sujets généraux puisque l'on est
dans la partie de discussion générale
est effectivement n'est pas rentré
encore de façon très approfondie dans
les questions financières mais
évidemment ça viendra évidemment ça
viendra je vais essayer de le résumer ce
que j'ai ressenti de de ses auditions de
ce qui s'est dit en respectant la fois
le travail de chacun mais en me disant
suffisamment de choses pour que notre
réunion
notre réunion de servent dans quel dans
quelles circonstances se déroule
finalement cette discussion sur ce texte
qui comprend pour moi deux parties une
première partie sur les compétences et
puis la conférence territoriale l'action
publique et la deuxième partie sur les
métropoles nouvelles collectivités
territoriales et l'appellation métropole
métropole d' équilibre qui est une sorte
de communauté urbaine améliorée voilà
donc sur la première partie du texte
j'ai noté d'abord que beaucoup de
personnes viennent et peut-être moi même
d'ailleurs lorsque j'ai été désigné en
pensant à bordés l'acte iii de la
décentralisation
mais même le branchu alice ça n'est pas
du tout ça
un sujet parce que des fois un peu c'est
ce qu'on attend des élections et faut
pas décevoir de trop les gens qui
attendent qu'ils attendent quelque chose
donc c'est pas l'acte iii de la
décentralisation j'ai bien noté ce
intervient après une fronde des élus
locaux contre un projet de
recentralisation qui avait été vécu
comme ça présenté partout en france et
qui avait abouti au résultat des
élections sénatoriales ce qui ne ne faut
pas oublier parce que le parallélisme
des formes
ce qu'une loi fait une loi peut le
défaire voilà ça vient ensuite au moment
d'une crise financière importante pour
les collectivités territoriales qui a
suivi la suppression brutale de la taxe
professionnelle et donc le déséquilibre
dans beaucoup de deux collectivités de
collectivités territoriales ça vient
enfin après le résultat du référendum en
alsace qui sans doute à une
participation faible mis en tout les cas
a indiqué que contrairement à tout ce
qui était présenté dans tous les grands
journaux dans toutes les revues de
sciences politiques de sciences
administratives et d'autres dans un pays
où c'est quand même toujours les
lecteurs qui décide
l'électeur a choisi la proximité plutôt
que l'unification technocratique donc
c'est danser dans ce c'est dans cet état
d'esprit finalement que les choses se
font alors que dix se disent les
personnes
je veux dire ce que j'ai ressenti
ensuite mon les comptes rendus sont en
train d'être tapés
je dirais pour 70% des gens qui sont
venus dans les auditions qui représente
des maires ruraux des maires de grandes
villes les présidents de conseils
généraux des présidents de conseils
régionaux et beaucoup de mes collègues
ont assisté aux réunions
ils sont extrêmement réservé sur la
conférence territoriale de lappion
public
pour plusieurs raisons je vais essayer
d'examiner rapidement
première raison ils lisent dans ce texte
une première partie on dit tout le monde
a la compétence générale
pourquoi pas certains non interviennent
les ans on aurait préféré choisir
j'avoue que c'est un peu mon cas je les
dis voilà
mais voilà c'est la compétence générale
pour tout le monde donc champagne pour
tout le monde mais il ya plus de quoi
payer le champagne
donc une fois que on a mis la compétence
générale ya plus de quoi payer le
champagne non réunissez vous pour savoir
comment on va boire le champagne est
donc soit sous l'autorité du préfet soit
sous la direction du président ou la
présidente du conseil régional
réunissez-vous cette fois ci pour savoir
comment les choses vont fonctionner et
les gens le ressentent très mal les
présidents de région une grande partie
d'entre eux en disant on va être
contestée dès qu'on va rentrer dans
cette affaire-là parce que personne va
vouloir d'une espèce de protecteur de
bohême moravie et donc il va y avoir des
alliances ça va être compliqué et
deuxièmement beaucoup d'élus considère
que ça va être une organisation
importante 40 50 60 70 personnes une
réunion supplémentaire pour pour les
élus avec voilà beaucoup de blabla quand
même beaucoup de blabla et que c'est pas
quelque chose d'efficace
et surtout ce qui je crois je veux pas
d'irriter mais ce qui soulève des
remarques c'est le côté uniforme
les gens disent bon voilà ça a été fait
en bretagne très bien
enfin est-ce qu'on peut faire autre
chose par exemple dans la franche comté
est ce que c'est quelque chose qui a
adapté à la région
à la région voilà bordelaise est là on
l'a entendu enfin je verrai les les
comptes-rendus je résume quand même
c'est ses 40 heures et donc la
conférence territoriale de l'action
publique finalement n'est pas quelque
chose qui est bien vu les gens
reconnaissent qui a besoin d'un lieu de
discussion d'ailleurs il y avait la
conférence des exécutifs
mais tel que la cc dimensionné considère
que cette chose d'invivable qui mettra
en cause l'autorité de certains
présidents et présidentes de conseil
régionaux au mieux fera juin des
alliances ici ou là entre tel
département tels agglomérations telles
communautés de communes et donc en gros
une résistance terrible en disant nous
n'en voulons pas j'essaye d'être clair
le plus rapidement le plus rapidement
possible sur les autres sur les autres
aspects sur les sur les métropoles alors
là je vais pas me hasarder dedans je
pense que sur la métropole c'est la
métropole lyonnaise il ya une
présentation là un accord en tous les
cas on avait senti que ça venait de loin
et qu' il y avait déjà des échanges
entre tel déficit de grands équipements
culturels tels emprunts toxiques quelque
chose d'un bon tout ça était
parfaitement huilé régler comme la
cuisine lyonnaise
et puis sur sur paris suffisamment de
parisiens dans la salle et je suis
suffisamment provincial pour ne pas m'en
mêler
/ / / marseille sur marseille bon sens
que c'est pas mûres c'est pas mûres
après après je terminerais là dessus
tous les tous les présidents et toutes
les organisations représentant les
grandes villes la dcf l'association des
communautés urbaines
on parlait pratiquement de façon
équanime et unique est une île et
univoque
en dix ans le statut de métropole le pci
cette fois ci en réponse à une question
de jacqueline gourault étant une sorte
de communauté urbaine améliorée nous
satisfait je pense que très honnêtement
sur l'ensemble des auditions qu'il ya eu
c'est l'endroit sûr qu'à lui quasiment
l'unanimité
à part une seule personne à l'intérieur
des voix la sueur sur le reste sur les
aspects financiers
je vais très vite on les a très peu
abordée je me contente de réunir
beaucoup de collègues en ce moment pour
moi sur le sujet suivant il m'étonnerait
que les dotations de l'état augmentent
premièrement deuxièmement la fiscalité
augmentant régulièrement un peu partout
celle de l'état et les collectivités
locales pourraient trouver ses limites
donc travaillons sur des ressources hors
fiscalité et on a commencé quand même à
trouver des pistes ce me paraît
important parce qu'il ya quand même
quelque chose qui inquiète beaucoup les
gens c'est comment nous allons pouvoir
continuer partout à investir et ça c'est
quand même aussi un sujet de
développement de l'économie réunir sous
la tutelle du préfet une région des gens
pour dire faut développer l'économie
c'est une chose le faire c'est mieux
voilà j'essaye de résumé monsieur
germain
monsieur claude dilain représentant e
rapporteur de la commission du
développement économique
merci monsieur le président mesdames les
ministres
au point où nous en sommes de l'examen
de cette loi je crois qu'effectivement
on peut dire qu'il ya un très large
accord une très forte volonté autour de
mots clarté et confiance mais à ces deux
mots je rajouterais deux autres mots
qu'on a beaucoup entendu aussi qu'ils
sont pas synonymes mais qui sont au
contraire presque conséquent de clarté
et de confiance ce sont les mots
simplification parce que si on veut être
clair il vaut mieux être pas trop
compliqué et puis spécificité parce que
si on fait confiance aux élus locaux
il faut accepter que le règlement des
problèmes ne soient pas forcément les
mêmes ici ou là d'ailleurs c'est inscrit
dans le texte puisqu'il ya déjà
officiellement très officiellement trois
spécificités qui sont donc paris lyon et
marseille
je pense que c'est pas étonnant qu'on
soit d'accord là dessus parce que dans
un pays décentralisé ce serait
inquiétant si on ne faisait pas
confiance aux élus locaux
donc je pense que là il ya une avancée
qui est bonne mais encore faut-il
qu'elle soit réellement vécu dans la loi
je vais donner juste un exemple je vais
être très court dans un domaine qui est
celui du domaine des affaires
économiques mais qui s'occupe aussi du
logement de la politique de la ville et
de l'urbanisme
il s'agit justement du logement et dans
le texte actuellement le la délégation
de compétence de l'état
en ce qui concerne le logement est
indissociable les cons les compétences
sont indissociables or les auditions
montré qu'il y avait quand même deux
conceptions de la métropole une
conception
je dirais stratégique et il ya des gens
qui nous ont dit ah mais nous on veut
l'aide à la pierre parce qu'on veut
effectivement être las les stratèges de
l'aménagement du territoire en terme de
logement mais alors le dalo
l'hébergement etc
il y a des gens qui savent faire mieux
que ça que nous mieux mieux que nous
laissons leur donc je veux bien prendre
l'aide à la pierre mais pas le reste il
y à d'autres à lyon par exemple où ils
ont dit nous on veut tous parce que les
deux les deux y'a pas bien mal les deux
se justifie parce que effectivement il
ya spécificité donc voilà si on veut
confiance peut-être qu'il faut prévoir
aussi que je vais bien compris pourquoi
c'est est indissociable enfin je crois
avoir compris et peut-être qu'on
pourrait revenir sur ça pour justement
qu'il y ait confiance et spécificités
moi je suis bref merci à nos trois
rapporteurs qui s'inscrit pour le débat
alors en premier nous allons mettre
madame bourreau parce qu'elle est
présidente
alors attendez non mais je prends les
attend dans madame bourreaux après je
prends tout de suite les les
candidatures à la parole
alors madame joissains monsieur de lège
monsieur d'allier monsieur kalt bac
il n'y a pas d'autres vocations
monsieur y est je pensais bien que
monsieur le président on y est allés
nous faire une une déclaration alors
après non
nous verrons nous verrons vous êtes
libre ob 12 en doutons pas y at il
d'autres d'autres inscrits alors
monsieur eblé bon écouter s'il ya des
vocations tardives
elles seront prises en considération
pour le moment nous avons sept inscrits
madame la présidente jacqueline gourault
mesdames les ministres mes chers
collègues dans ce premier texte
il y a quelque chose sur lequel je crois
devoir intervenir après avoir entendu un
certain nombre de nos collègues de
différentes régions et de différentes
associations
nous avons un problème je dirais non
seulement sémantique mais devant quand
on parle de métropole parce qu'en fait
on s'aperçoit que le mot métropole
recouvre des réalités ou des projets
différents et donc on parle de paris
lyon marseille bon on dit la métropole
et puis on reçoit nos amis de brest
d'autres régions françaises et qui eux
aussi parle de métropole en fait on
parle pas de la même chose
il y en a qui parlent d'une d'un
établissement public de coopération
interministérielle minable on est
fatigué on est fatigué intercommunal de
pc je dirais une commune communauté
urbaine encore plus intégrée
voilà un et puis il y en a qui vont
jusqu'à parler comme à lyon d'une
collectivité territoriale qui s'appelle
métropole donc je pense que sacré dans
l'appellation c'est tout bête mais des
confusions des angoisses les angoisses
aussi particulier pour les communes qui
constituent les établissements publics
parce que ils s'imaginent que c'est la
disparition des communes alors que il
faut à la fin vous voyez ce que je veux
dire
donc il faut bien faire la distinction
entre et essayer de trouver une réponse
je dirais un vocabulaire
qui montre bien qu'il y a différentes
organisations parce que je crois qu
autrement ça fera une grande confusion
je voulais le dire parce que ça met
vraiment apparu comme une évidence
après avoir entendu tous nos collègues
de toutes les régions françaises
on a parlé d'actions publiques il ya une
autre chose que je voulais vous dire
très vite puisqu'on parle d'action
publique
il faut que dans notre pays restituer au
préfet de département des pouvoirs
qu'ils ont perdu
je crois que ça c'est quelque chose qu
attendent les ai vus sur le territoire
français merci merci madame joissains
oui bonjour voila le ministre madame le
ministre sera de marie simplement moi je
vais vous que mon message est toujours
un peu ça peut apparaître un petit peu
redondant néanmois comme le disait le
rapporteur monsieur germain à l'instant
le territoire n'est pas prêt pour une
métropole la métropole et je citerai les
deux ministres en reparlant de confiance
de clarté a besoin effectivement de ces
éléments pour fonctionner parce qu'elle
n'a pas un caractère d'obligation
l'équité territoriale de surveillance à
cette équité et nos territoires sont
très jeune dans l'intercommunalité
cela fait 10 12 ans simplement que les
communautés sont constitués nous
commençons apprendre à travailler
ensemble
il est évident que la ville de marseille
qui fait 46% tu m'aimes de la population
de ce qui devrait être le périmètre de
cette métropole aura une influence très
forte ce qui ne peut que faire peur aux
petites communes parce que nous n'avons
pas encore une fois l'habitude de
travailler ensemble c'est sud le sud n'a
pas du tout la même mentalité que le
nord un joli but hier où j'ai vu encore
une fois avec une grande stupéfaction
certains territoires appelé de leurs
voeux
une métropole je pense à la bretagne et
je sais que l'affluence bretonne n'est
pas étrangère à ce texte non plus voilà
et de fait de fait aujourd'hui il ya
d'une part l'état du territoire les
mentalités qui règne les risques que
courent nos communes de moindre
importance par rapport à la ville phare
et je ne parle pas dans le fantasme
quand je dis cela j'en parle en
connaissance de cause par rapport à
d'autres collectivités territoriales qui
sont à l'oeuvre sur ce territoire et ce
n'est pas facile ni pour les uns ni pour
les autres
ensuite ce périmètre nous paraît un peu
curieux parce qu'effectivement les
territoires de camargue les opci
camargue demande à ne pas être exclue
notamment d'une compétence comme celle
des transports parce qu'ils sont en
grosse difficulté financière et au
niveau de l'emploi donc ils ont besoin
aussi d'être desservies comme le reste
du territoire des bouches du rhône et
puis enfin enfin nous avons fait une
proposition
c'est à dire que le sud des particuliers
personne n'a trop envie de travailler
avec l'autre néanmoins les choses se
sont quand même fait au niveau des
intercommunalités et aujourd'hui nous
sommes 109 maire vincent de communes sur
118 dont 12 qui font partie de la
communauté urbaine à ne pas vouloir
entrer dans la métropole mais tout de
même avoir travaillé ensemble dans le
sens de ce que ce que souhaiterait
l'unité nationale et 7 ce travail en
commun nous a conduit dans un premier
temps dans l'ensemble de nos communes a
voté pour un pôle métropolitain qui
était l'alternative donné à l'époque par
la loi sarkozy aux métropoles
et puis dans un second temps à concevoir
un petit peu ce qui va se faire a priori
sur la ville de paris c'est à dire un
établissement public un établissement
public où l'état pourrait être présent
et qui nous permettrait de mettre en
oeuvre les compétences stratégiques
le gouvernement nous nous à nous a
beaucoup écouté nous sommes rencontrés à
de multiples fois avec mme lebranchu et
je sais que les conseils de territoires
qui sont issus de cette réflexe de la
réflexion gouvernementale
viennent du fait du moins je le suppose
aisément que vous vous êtes rendu compte
que nous commencions à travailler
ensemble et que nous avions besoin de
continuer à travailler de concert
j'ai l'impression en lisant le texte sur
le conseil de terry sur les conseils des
territoires que cela a été un petit peu
calqué sur le modèle des mairies
d'arrondissement
le problème c'est que nous n'avons pas
d'autonomie financière contrairement aux
mairies d'arrondissement mais le secteur
et que dans le même temps les dotations
effectivement seront re délégué aux
métropoles les compétences seront re
délégué aux métropoles qui suppose aussi
des transferts de personnel énorme
contre lesquels la cgt a déjà manifesté
à marseille et ses transferts de
personnels ne seront les sables que sur
cinq ans ce qui va ce risque fort dans
la région où quand même les le sang est
bouillant un de faire de provoquer des
mouvements sociaux importants d'une part
et ensuite un lissage sur cinq ans par
l'eau ça veut dire aussi des des hausses
de millions d'euros au niveau des
transferts scénario tout cela m'amène à
penser que le modèle des opci qui
demeure avec un établissement public
seul compétent sur les compétences les
plus stratégiques serait de bon augure
tout au moins pendant une certaine
période pendant quelques années qui nous
permettrait d'apprendre à mettre nos
compétences en commun et nos talents en
commun
voilà merci vous savez tous les français
ont le sens républicain et sont adeptes
de la solidarité du nord au sud et même
en bretagne c'est pourquoi monsieur de
l'effarement différemment bien sûr la
diversité c'est notre chance
alors monsieur de lège
merci monsieur le président mesdames les
ministres permettait un breton de
s'exprimer et jeffrey 3,3 observation la
première sur la la conférence
territoriale je vois bien d'où elle est
inspirée et je ne rentrerai pas dans
l'appréciation personnelle que je peux
porter sur le fonctionnement de cette
conférence en bretagne simplement pour
souligner que vous avez madame le
ministre à plusieurs reprises employer
le mot confiance faire confiance aux
élus et par conséquent je m'interroge
beaucoup sur la nécessité de développer
l'article 3 sur les conférences
territoriales de façon aussi précise et
d'encadrer leurs créations de façon
aussi précise en indiquant par exemple
que la conférence territoriale ne
réunira les opci que de plus de 50000
habitants est ce que c'est du domaine de
la loi d'aller jusque dans ce détail
peut-être que dans d'autres régions
on préférera des ep six de plus petite
taille et vous le savez en bretagne
certaine paix s'ils sont exclus du
fameux bessette
je le dis d'autant plus fortement que
pour créer cette conférence territoriale
en région bretonne le président le drian
n'a pas eu besoin de la loi et par
conséquent sont ils allés aussi loin
et j'ajoute petit clin d'oeil de
quelques contradictions
la région bretagne a contribué il y à un
mois à une réflexion sur la
décentralisation dans la perspective de
ce texte et la conférence territoriale
n'est pas d'accord avec la position de
la région donc je crois qu'il faut être
très très prudent sur cette conférence
territoriale et si elle doit voir le
jour
il semble que le texte doit être
considérablement allégées
dans le sens du mot conscience que vous
avez employé tout à l'heure ma deuxième
question a trait à la clause de
compétence générale et à la libre
administration des collectivités
territoriales que vous avez rappelé et
je serais tenté de dire mais comment
concilier ces deux principes avec
lesquels nous sommes tout à fait en
phase avec des dispositions même du
texte et je pense à l'article 9 qui dit
que la région ne peut accorder aucune
subvention d'investissement ou de
fonctionnement au projet des
départements de communes cetera et
cetera qui ne respectent pas les
orientations fixées par le schéma
régional
on voit bien que la déjà nous sommes
entre elles d'attenté à au principe de
la libre administration et de la clause
de compétence générale en soit ma
dernière observation a trait à l'article
31 et aux conseils de territoire vous
nous avez dit il s'agit de clarifier les
compétences
il s'agit d'une droite simplification on
voit qu'on crée le pc de type nouveau la
métropole et pourquoi pas avec des
compétences particulières et là dessus
je n'ai pas d'états d'âme mais on est en
train de rajouter une nouvelle couche
avec ce conseil de territoire qui sera
une sorte d'intermédiaire entre la
commune et la métropole
voilà les trois observations bretonne
que je voulais faire mais monsieur
d'allier merci monsieur le président
mais la ministre dans leurs propos
liminaire le président soeur et vous
madame escoffier avait utilisé deux
termes simplicité efficacité
je dois dire qu'en regardant les
propositions vous faites pour l'île de
france et pour la métropole du grand
paris j'ai du mal à m'y retrouver
simplicité écoutez on va boucler
l'interco dans la première couronne
on va rajouter une couche avec la
métropole du grand paris on va créer le
conseil de l'ensemble des maires de
l'ile-de-france
honnêtement je ne sais pas où est la
simply la simplicité ou la
simplification en matière d'efficacité
si on regarde particulièrement une
couche d'une compétence comme le
logement
je sais pas très bien ce que votre texte
va apporter je sais pas si on regarde ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui les maires
tiennent le permis de construire très
bien on a des plh et d'épée élus qui
sont communes aux pourrait devenir
intercommunaux pourquoi pas mais lorsque
l'épée et lâches sont élaborées dans le
porter à connaissance du préfet l'état
fixe les objectifs notamment pour les
communes qui sont sous article 55 de la
loi sru donc les contraintes en termes
de construction et par catégorie de
logement social intermédiaires ou
accession à la propriété sont fixés donc
puisque l'objectif c'est de construire
est d'inciter les villes à construire il
ya déjà des moyens on voit comment c'est
fait donc en région ile de france
aujourd'hui on a le sdrif qui fixait des
objectifs très large de construction qui
s'appliquait grosso modo avec une
répartition par département et puis au
bout du compte ce sont les communes qui
sont en charge
qu'est ce que vous nous proposez pour
améliorer cela
les maires tiendront toujours les permis
de construire le plh le paie et le pnud
pourront être intercommunaux très bien
par plaques de 300000 habitants très
bien est-ce que c'est par plaques de
300000 habitants mesdames les ministres
qu'on doit penser la mixité sociale en
seine-saint-denis est ce que quand on
aura coupé la seine saint denis en
quatre ou cinq plaques de trois à quatre
cent mille habitants
on aura changé quoi que ce soit en
matière de rééquilibrage de la métropole
entre les zones qui concentre le plus de
logements sociaux et les autres moi je
ne vois pas et vous pourrez
effectivement confié à cette métropole
de paris je sais plus exactement quelle
est enfin on verra quelle sera son nom
mais enfin vous pouvez lui confier
effectivement servir l'objectif de
réaliser un document qu'ils soient prêts
qu'ils soient opposables à ces plaques
de trois cent mille habitants
je suis pas sûr que ce sera beaucoup
plus efficace que ce que nous avons
aujourd'hui quand l'état fuite les
objectifs de construction directement
aux communes alors certes on pourrait
considérer que les élus le feront à la
place de l'état mais l'etat sera
toujours le garant de l'application de
l'article 55 de la loi sru
qu'est-ce que ça va changer et où est la
plus grande efficacité en matière de
logement par exemple puisque c'est
effectivement l'un des problèmes majeurs
ceci étant dit pour revenir à la
solution vous nous proposez il y avait
de grandes hypothèses la première
hypothèse c'était celle de la métropole
intégré c'est celle que je soutiens
depuis 2008
alors effectivement on peut débattre
sans fin du périmètre de ses pétro paul
moi j'avais proposé le périmètre des
départements de la petite couronne parce
que constitutionnellement c'est possible
parce qu'effectivement il ya quand même
une grande distinction en termes de
territoire entre la petite et la grande
couronne
effectivement pour autant le périmètre
les rues urbaines n'est pas celle là
enfin il y avait quand même une certaine
logique et on aurait très bien pu
organiser la petite couronne donc la
métropole intégré d'une manière et la
grande couronne d'une autre il y avait
une deuxième vision qui était la vision
régionale avec effectivement un
renforcement des pouvoirs de la région
c'est d'ailleurs ce qu'elle demandait la
région ayant tellement peur de la
constitution de cette métropole
et effectivement après voir au travers
des intercommunalités ce que l'on
pouvait faire mais se poser encore le
problème des départements que finalement
vous ne traitez pas et notamment ceux de
la petite couronne
vous venez ajouter un énième cataplasmes
sur la jambe de bois de la péréquation
des départements en petite couronne vous
créer le fonds qui vise effectivement à
sauver la seine-saint-denis de la
faillite mais madame la ministre
mesdames les ministres
ça n'est que reculer pour mieux sauter
vous ne réglerez pas le problème sur le
fond vous ne la règle et repas la
solution que j'avais proposée qui
consistait à fusionner les quatre
départements de paris et la petite
couronne
sans même rajouté une dotation
supplémentaire vous aviez un effet
périmètre énorme pour financer le rsa la
dépendance et c'est là les départements
restent et vous cherchez encore un aîné
un énième mécanisme je pense que ça ne
sera pas ça ne sera pas plus efficace
donc vous aviez la version métropole
intégré et la version région et vous
arrivez avec un texte qui n'est ni l'un
ni l'autre
résultat vous ne fait effectivement que
des mécontents mais peut-être avez-vous
pensé qu'en supprimant rien et en
rajoutant une couche
ça serait comme par le passé finalement
trou tout le monde y trouverait son
compte mais madame la ministre
c'est exactement le contraire qui se
passe et je ne vois pas comment ce texte
sera adopté alors
vous rajoutez cette couche sur le
périmètre de l aire urbaine
quand je pense que ceux qui critiquaient
mon rapport qui crée une métropole
intégré pour 7 millions d'habitants en
dix ans c'est un truc énorme c'est un
machin ça marchera pas vous nous
proposer quelque chose sur un périmètre
qui compte 10 millions d'habitants dans
une région qui en fait 12
alors là excusez moi j'ai un peu de mal
à comprendre
j'ai un peu de mal à comprendre alors je
vais en venir à mes questions je
développerai tous ces arguments lorsque
le texte viendra en débat mais il ya
quand même quelques quelques questions à
poser est ce que les limites
départementales seront devront
obligatoirement être respectée lors de
la création des intercoms en première
couronne je pose la question alors vous
dites non moi je
mais c'est la loi la loi permet de faire
des intercommunalités pas eh bien sachez
monsieur sachez monsieur le président ce
faire que lorsque le val d'oise a sorti
son schéma de coopération intercommunale
la ville de bologne qui souhaitais
mettre en interco avec le bourget et
drancy n'a pas pu le faire parce que le
préfet du val d'oise ne l'a pas accepté
mais monsieur laissez-moi développer le
sur le président et la possibilité que
je veux je pose la question parce qu'il
ya de bonnes raisons il ya de bonnes
raisons de la pause et ce qui va se
passer en seine-saint-denis dans ce cas
là je vous le dis la plupart des villes
vont chercher à se tourner vers
l'extérieur
bon c'est le constat c'est ce qui va se
passer vous verrez je sais pas si c'est
une bonne ou une mauvaise idée à partir
du moment où vous conservez les
départements parce que là où sera la
cohérence d'ensemble
je ne la verrai pas une question ensuite
sur l'étude d'impact qui me semble quand
même assez légères ou alors j'ai pas
trouvé la bonne feuille
concernant le coût de la mise en place
des intercoms en première couronne
parisienne
ça va coûter combien à l' enveloppe
normée combien de centaines de millions
d'euros
est-ce que vous pouvez nous le dire
parce qu'un milliard sac de moins
l'année prochaine un milliard cinq de
moins l'année suivante c'est sans
compter le coût de la mise en place de
l'interco en première couronne
parisienne et du bouclage mais il y
avait peu à faire en grande couronne ça
va se chiffrer en centaines de millions
d'euros
mes chers collègues de province
vous invite à penser à cela et enfin une
dernière question beaucoup nous disent
mais cette solution n'est qu'une étape
vers effectivement quelque chose de
mieux ça viendra écoutez je veux bien le
croire mais effectivement quand on aura
mis en place ce système là on en prend
mais la mise pour 20 ans ou pour 25 ans
le temps de boucler ces interco on ne
reviendra pas dessus
cependant je lis la presse et je suis
tombé sur une déclaration du premier
ministre qui disait en 2020 élection du
président du grand paris au suffrage
universel direct
je me suis dit génial mais je sais pas
s'il a pas 10 5 mois je les lui en tous
les cas où alors l'article et est
erronée c'est absolument impossible sur
la base du projet que vous nous
présentez puisqu'on a des communes on va
avoir les intercours par plaques de 300
milles et on va avoir la super interco
qui rassemblera les présidents de ces
plaques de 300 milles on est sur un
système à trois couches et on irait
élire au suffrage universel
le président de l'ensemble ça ne ça ne
tient pas cinq minutes la route
si on avait une métropole intégrer
effectivement on peut élire le président
au suffrage universel avec ce schéma là
on ne le peut pas donc est ce que oui ou
non ce sujet sur la table
est ce que l'objectif et 2020 pour aller
vers autre chose
auquel cas franchement pas sont tout de
suite à autre chose parce que la version
vous nous proposez à mon avis elle n'a
que des inconvénients elle ne fera que
compliquer si que complexifier le
système et en plus elle coûtera très
cher à mon sens aux contribuables et à
l' enveloppe normée
merci monsieur d'allier monsieur kalt en
bacs
oui merci monsieur le président mesdames
ministre
tout d'abord je crois que le premier
mérite du texte est vraiment d'affirmer
le fait métropolitain qui est indéniable
incontestable et qui méritent d'être
traitées par une loi
ma conviction est que ces métropoles
vont forcément se faire au détriment du
département qui est une forme
d'organisation qui est bien adapté au
monde rural mais qui le
on le voit bien n'est plus adapté dans
les grandes agglomérations
alors c'est vrai je partage pas toutes
les réflexions et analyses de notre
collègue d'allier mais en ile-de-france
pour revenir à une région que je connais
bien on sait bien que nous avons besoin
d'apporter des réponses à des problèmes
concrets de nos concitoyens en matière
de transport de logement d'emploi
d'équipement public qu'aujourd'hui on
voit tous les dysfonctionnements et
toutes les difficultés et que on
comprend l'intérêt de ce grand conseil
métropolitain mais on a du mal à
percevoir l'intérêt de cette couche
supplémentaire qui va venir se rajouter
aux communes aux interco par plaques au
département à la région
il faut vraiment mettre ce conseil
métropolitain en perspective
et moi je partage assez en la vie du
sénateur gagner il faut qu'on la
perspective à terme de la disparition
des départements dans la zone agglomérée
pour que le conseil d'agglomération le
conseil métropolitain est vraiment des
compétences fortes et une légitimité
donc tout ça doit passer par une étape
mais dès maintenant il faut définir
l'étape qui sera l'étape de la fusion le
sait